cediendo a la presión de la calle los
legisladores acordaron reescribir
completamente el polémico proyecto de
ley de seguridad que haría ilegal
registrar y compartir imágenes que
identifiquen a los agentes de policías
tras las masivas protestas del fin de
semana nos aboque de luz fascista
sabemos que las dudas aún persisten
debemos eliminar estas dudas y cuando
esta falta de comprensión se intensifica
en un tema tan fundamental tenemos el
deber de hacernos preguntas
colectivamente y colectivo el ministro
de interior ya saluda a mano e insistió
en defender la iniciativa según él la
protección policial y la libertad de
prensa van de la mano
y mi profunda convicción y la del
gobierno es que debemos mantener
absolutamente lo que se ha convertido en
la base creo de la protección deseada
por los legisladores y el gobierno que
es la protección de los policías y
gendarmes durante las operaciones
policiales no están suficientemente
protegidos
repito no voy a cambiar mis creencias en
su visión más de 133.000 personas 46.000
sólo en parís se manifestaron contra el
proyecto de ley a favor de la libertad
de expresión
las manifestaciones se produjeron
después de la publicación de un vídeo en
el que se veía a un hombre golpeado por
tres policías que emanuel makoun ha
calificado de vergonzoso para francia